l'industrie de la restauration au québec
c'est plus de 20 mai l'établissement ce
secteur emploie plus de deux cent
quarante mille personnes
l'impact sur le pib est évalué à 6
milliards 800 millions de dollars en
2018 le secteur de la restauration
commerciale a dépensé quatre milliards
700 millions de dollars pour l'achat de
produits bioalimentaires dont plus de la
moitié de cette somme a servi à l'achat
de produits québécois
andrée lamontagne ministre de
l'agriculture des pêcheries et de
l'alimentation bonsoir monsieur la
montagne bonsoir monsieur fillion alors
distance de 2 m aujourd'hui pour la
réouverture des restaurants ou des
barrières physiques mais voulait c'est
quand même au bon jugement des
restaurateurs le nombre de personnes
admises comment on va pouvoir vérifier
si on va écouter c'est exactement ça
c'est le étant donné que chaque
établissement peut avoir une
configuration physique différente la la
santé publique et la csst ont jugé le
que de simplement demandé de s'assurer
d'avoir la distanciation deux mètres
cela permettrait aux restaurateurs aux
entrepreneurs de d'user de leur
créativité de capacité de s'adapter l'on
peut trouver les meilleures conditions
pour opérer leur restaurant donc on ne
dit pas 25 50 75 % de capacité on n'est
pas dans ces chiffres là donc ça ce sera
à géométrie variable en quelque sorte
selon les endroits l'espace que les
différents établissements auront
exactement et comment cet espace de
configurer vous allégez aussi les
exigences pour la vente d'alcool par les
restaurants et la vente d'alcool au
restaurant sans nécessairement manger un
repas ça c'est dans le projet de loi 61
et un permis d'alcool aussi pour un
restaurant sur une terrasse ou est tout
à fait alors exactement il ya des
ajustements ou d'une entente qui était
conclue entre la ministre de sécurité
publique mena mme guilbeault et la régie
des alcools et des jeux de courses pour
faire en sorte de faciliter la
l'agrandissement la modification de
terrasses ou qu'un entrepreneur
restaurateurs puisse obtenir un permis
pour vendre d'alcool sur une terrasse
tout naturellement selon les conditions
de l'accord dit de 19 puis ça soit fait
naturellement là en accord avec les
municipalités et l'assouplissement des
rêves
est ce qu'il est pour toujours on
seulement durant la période de la cog
hill 19
quand on parle pour les terrasses là
dans un premier temps ce qu'on a ce qui
était convenu le c'était pour pour cet
été pour cet été pour l'été mais est ce
qu'on pourrait faire du ménage dans tous
ses permis qui sont quand même assez
complexe à souhait à supporter pour bien
des restaurateurs certainement monsieur
fusion que je vous dis que mon mini
serres de culture g en train de piloter
la modernisation de la loi sur les
produits alimentaires et puis toute la
question des permis du sol je peux vous
dire qu'on ya du ménage qui va se faire
au cours des neuf années qui s'en
viennent des fois dans un même
restaurant dépendamment des locaux
partie bar partie restaurant partie
terrasse parti en avant en partie en
arrière et huit permis pour un même le
cas ça vient compliquer la tout à fait
là je peux pas être plus d'accord avec
vous le monsieur fillon
pourquoi les restaurants aujourd'hui et
pas les bars bars étaient aujourd'hui
c'est 22000 l'établissement qu'ils
disposent de permis de restauration de
préparation de l'imac sont émis par le
mapaq et puis naturellement mais peu
importe le nom qu'on utilise mais tout
établissement aujourd'hui qui assure ces
lieux des équipements de préparations
alimentaires que du personnel qui est
pendant que le commerçant exploite le
que du personnel qui travaille et à
opérer ces équipements de préparations
alimentaires là tous les commerces qui
ont ces permis de préparations
alimentaires la leçon là le droit
d'ouvrir à partir du 15 juin de partout
au québec ont qu un bar un restaurant
qui est un permis de restaurants bien
sûr pour ouvrir un bar un permis deux
restaurants de préparations alimentaires
pu rouvrir mais un bar qui n'a pas ça un
barbare seulement la lui mais pas ouvrir
c'est ce que la santé publique est pas
rendu là encore d'autoriser le de
confinement ou l'ouverture des barbares
comme vous êtes tôt mais je devrais vous
rappeler par contre monsieur fillion
qu'un bar qui offre un service de
restauration va avoir l'autorisation
d'ouvrir pour l'activité de restauration
mais à partir de 9 heures le soir tard
le soir là s'ils veulent transformer son
son opération pour avoir d'autres
occupations et d'autres activités que ce
soit la danse ou des choses comme ça ça
serait pas permis alors l'établissement
ce qu'on annonce aujourd'hui c'est pour
l'opération la de la restauration de
tous ces établissements
pourquoi ça soir au restaurant et
prendre de l'alcool sans manger
c'est pourquoi s'asseoir dans un bar et
prendre de l'alcool c'est pas la même
chose que s'asseoir dans un restaurant
et prendre de l'alcool sans manger
écoutez c'est une c'est une question de
contexte demande là elle remonte à
longtemps de la part des restaurateurs
et puis c'est l'idée que souvent il peut
arriver que des gens qui sont assis de
trois personnes qui mangent quelqu'un
qui est l'up normalement les
accompagnent ne mange pas il voulait
prendre un verre c'était compliqué c'est
plutôt dans cette classe et pas dans un
optique où les gens vont investir un
restaurant pour aller consommer
uniquement de l'alcool parce qu'on s'est
consommé de l'alcool avec la nourriture
soit pas tout à fait le même impact
qu'on selon bras seulement de l'alcool
mais dans le contexte actuel vous pensez
pas que des restaurants qui vont virer
en bar le finalement parce que des gens
qui vont aller prendre un verre dans un
restaurant parce que le restaurant est
ouvert et que le restaurant peut vendre
de l'alcool sans nécessairement qu'on
mange
alors que les bars peuvent plus vendre
d'alcool
je vous dirai à la base tout la
réouverture de l'économie monsieur
fillion l'oeil impact le kaki qu'il faut
qu'il existe la hante
l'opérateur dans ce que si le
restaurateur et puis le client
et puis le succès de ce déconfinement de
spectre et où il tient réouverture là on
va vraiment être en fonction de
l'adhésion de chacune des parties à ce
qui est demandé par la santé publique
parce que naturellement si on restait qu
on respecte pas ces règles là on
uniquement au risque de se mettre à mal
et finalement que le déconfinement sur
un succès alors depuis le début la poche
du gouvernement le sait de faire
confiance aux gens faire confiance aux
opérateurs pour s'assurer de mettre en
place les conditions gagnantes pour les
ouvertures de commerces mais aussi faire
confiance aux clients qui vont être
contents parce que les gens admirent les
respects real alors de mettre en péril
on a l'impression qu'il ne fait pas
confiance au bar que vous faites pas
confiance aux propriétaires de bars
aujourd'hui dans ce cas là vous savez y
avait une séquence qui avait été
annoncée le par le gouvernement en
fonction de ce que la santé publique
bouhlel on est à la phase six celle s
étaient les restaurants mais toute la
question de la décision qui ouvre et à
quelle séquence de soi je vous
rappellerai le clip une décision
gouvernementale c'est vraiment
une décision de la santé publique après
100 d'accord le travail le pour réunir
les conditions pour l'ouverture ça se
fait de concert avec la csst
puis après ça on a l'autorisation de
procéder la audi confinement d'un
secteur andrée lamontagne ministre de
l'alimentation de l'agriculture des
pêcheries et merci merci beaucoup tête
d'obésité fillion bonne soirée